[Music]
customer in my store attacking
attacking customers
second
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
right before christmas um lapd went into
a burlington coat factory in north
hollywood california and murdered two
people daniel leno lopez and valentina
orellana peralta they went in there with
no regard for human life
with no attempt to de-escalate and they
murdered two people
breaking news police opened fire at a
north hollywood department store killing
a suspect and an innocent teenage girl a
tragic end to an attack by a man in a
burlington clothing store as police
opened fire on the man a bullet struck
and killed a 14 year old girl so if you
look at the video you see someone who is
ready to kill someone um he sort of you
know goes to the back of the the vehicle
he gets the gun out makes sure it's
loaded and checks everything and he's
going in there with a mission he's going
to kill someone and i doubt he's
actually caring about who he actually
kills you see him pass you know this
sort of fun little picture of a of a
black family you know and he goes up
this escalator partners his his other
cops there they have some awareness of
the situation that that there are other
people in the store if you look at the
video again the the lesson lethal is
there there is a there's a cop there
waiting to you know uh shoot someone
with a less than lethal which we know
can cause a lot of damage to people we
know that it can incapacitate people but
uh they chose to escalate the situation
as as they always do
you got it you got it okay
[Applause]
you can hear his partner say stuff like
hold up and slow down but the officer
who we now know as officer jones just
starts firing
uh he fires a couple of shots and one of
them uh did not hit daniel the one of
them hit a wall that ended up being the
wall to a dressing room that then hit
valentina and if you really listen
closely with some headphones on you can
hear the screams of valentina's mother
after valentina has just been shot
the de-escalation never crossed his mind
there's not a moment where he takes a
pause where he takes a step back where
he talks to someone says hey what's the
situation he's going in there with the
intent to kill him as soon as he finds
who he's looking for he doesn't he
doesn't even care to check on the person
who's down and bleeding he actually is
just there to shoot the guy uh daniel
had they you know sort of uh hit daniel
with with a less than lethal valentina
would still be here they would have
incapacitated him arrested him and that
would have been the end of it
unfortunately we lost valentina that day
to the lapd but unfortunately that
wasn't the first time it happened
my name is albert corrado and my
innocent sister mellie corrado was
murdered by the lapd in 2018.
[Music]
[Music]
now at five you are looking live at
breaking news from silver lake a police
standoff at a crowded trader joe's store
police dash cam shows how quickly it all
happened suspect gene atkins firing at
officers
they fire back
in slow motion from a police body cam
you can see the door to trader joe's
opening you do not clearly see mellie
corrado she is shot goes back in and
collapses shot by an lapd officer
[Music]
my sister was killed because this guy
jean atkins had had kidnapped his
girlfriend he shot his grandmother a few
times and stolen her car and someone had
reported the car stolen and and reported
what had just happened and the cops met
up with him and and they pursued him for
about 45 minutes he took him on a ride
all over la they had many chances to
kind of apprehend him or to do some
maneuvers to kind of
incapacitate his car and they chose not
to um
and and finally they they kind of came
into silver lake uh his tire had blown
out and and it crashed into a pole
outside of the trader joe's and he
decided to get out of the car and run
inside of the trader joe's they say that
he shot at them uh while he was getting
out of the car to go into trader joe's
but that's never been proven but he ran
inside and as he was running inside the
lapd chose to escalate the situation and
to fire inside of the grocery store and
one of those bullets hit gene atkins it
hit him in the arm and he survived and
is now facing trial but one of those
bullets hit my sister melly who was
responding to what she thought was a car
accident when the car crashed into the
pole she thought someone was there who
needed help and so she went out to go
help them told everybody in the store
i've got this don't worry about it and
because of that she was shot by by one
of lapd's bullets um and and you know uh
within 45 minutes she was she was gone
she had been shot and and uh in a place
where where she bled out and and she
died
all i can say about mellie is that you
know she knew how to make people feel
loved uh the the times i miss her the
most are when i'm having a birthday
party when i'm having some celebration
of life um and you know she always knew
how to make you feel special on your
special day she always knew how to make
you feel like you were the only person
in the world that mattered and i think
that's the thing i miss most about her
we all woke up thinking it'd be a normal
day
a year ago mellie woke up she went to
work and she never made it back home
the reaction of the lapd was basically
to to wash their hands of it so um
initially they had told the la times
that gene atkins the suspect was the one
who killed mellie when that we knew that
wasn't true everyone in the store knew
it wasn't true we had been told by
people who were inside of the store who
had seen mellie get shot from a bullet
that came in through the door uh that
that it was not it was not jean atkins
it was the lapd from the from the offset
they were trying to deny responsibility
they were trying to say it was someone
else's fault and their sort of you know
response to us was basically we're
really sorry um
you know this happens and policing is
tough but you know that he was a bad guy
and we were trying to stop him and um
we're really sorry about your sister i
mean you know mayor garcetti and a
couple people and police chief moore
held a press conference kind of telling
telling the world what had happened and
and they were you know again mournful
and regretful and we're so sorry but but
never was there a time where they were
you know criticizing the officers who
did it there was two officers who were
in pursuit of gene atkins and and one of
them fired the fatal bullet they both
fired into the store but they're still
on the force as of today that nothing
was done there was no you know obviously
no prosecution uh they were not fired
they got two weeks off to fill out
paperwork the two officers who killed
mellie actually one of them got fourteen
thousand dollars worth of overtime in
2018 when emily was killed the other got
seven thousand dollars in overtime on
top of being paid close to 100 grand and
then on top of being paid another 37 000
in benefits so they were you know one of
them cleared 150 grand the year they
killed melly the other you know cleared
a little less than that but they were
still on the force they were still out
there the officer is never charged
nothing is done to change it and and
there is no accountability
do you feel any remorse for the cop that
killed your sister
you know what i i gotta say if if that
cop is is if the cop who killed mellie
is watching this if you're looking for
forgiveness you will find none here to
me they are an agent of of a white
supremacist system that that all it does
is is bleed money from communities and
cities and and it kills people it it
incarcerates people it does things to
justify its own existence it does things
in the names in the name of the policing
apparatus so to me i don't have any any
sort of remorse for this person i don't
feel bad for this person because they
chose to do that they chose to escalate
the situation and to me um you know i'm
a believer in that that you if you make
a decision you have to live with that
decision i hope that you are haunted for
the rest of your life i hope that you
relive that moment because i am reliving
that moment my father is reliving that
moment everybody who knew melly is
reliving the moment that you chose to
take her life and and that's why i
always say it's it's a murder mellie was
murdered she was not just killed by the
lapd she was murdered because they
intended to kill someone and they they
killed someone
so you know 2018 july 21st was when
mellie was killed she was murdered by
the lapd uh you know a little over three
years later we have the murder of
valentina or jana peralta happening in
basically the almost the exact same
instance uh cop goes into a store and
fires and and doesn't care who he hits
and that there has been no change in the
way that they they react to these things
i think shows that there's a there's not
a desire to to change there's not a
desire to be held accountable to do
anything in a manner that would save
more people i mean i think we need to
have this conversation of whether police
are actually doing what they're supposed
to do right i mean all we've ever done
is either blindly support the police and
give them money to do what they keep
doing or we say well we're going to
reform these these people we're going to
reform them and give them more training
which ultimately means more money the
more money you give to police the more
people die that is the the simplest
calculus i can give you it is not uh
hyperbole it is not exaggeration it is
the truth the more money that the police
gets the more people who are going to be
killed because they are emboldened by
that they are emboldened by city council
by by politicians
by by just the media i'm a i'm an
abolitionist to me
policing is is not doing
any service to the people of of this
country of this city when you take money
from communities and give it to the
policing apparatus you were taking away
uh people's livelihood you know the
issue is not we don't want public safety
it's that we want it in a way that is
equitable for everybody that doesn't
that doesn't sacrifice people like
mellie people like valentina so a lot of
people i think are kind of waking up to
the fact that policing will never serve
us and and for us to try to ask them to
serve us is is futile and and foolish at
this point
we have to we have to start scraping
away at it before we actually start to
build something new you don't just say
tomorrow okay la you know police are
gone and now let's you know it's
obviously not going to happen that
quickly and we we know as abolitionists
that it's a long road but we have to
continually prove to people that once
you take a big chunk from here then
things will get better it has to be an
experiment it has to be us being bold
and brave and saying we need to try
something new because the alternative is
we keep this system that exists that is
not helping anybody and and and then it
will not just be
mellie corrado or valentina so we have
to have this conversation that we have
to prove it to you we're going to take
money from here we're going to put it
there and you're going to see exactly
how much better life is going to be
after mellie was killed i i did a lot of
you know grieving and searching and
trying to figure out what my life was
going to be and um you know after about
a year of of doing that i realized that
not only would i be mellie's grieving
brother i would i would become her
biggest advocate and so i got involved
in in a lot of uh you know social
justice stuff and and local community
organizing and uh one day it kind of hit
me you know what um i'm learning that
that you know policing
is such such a big issue that affects
every other issue in a city homelessness
and housing and and everything park
services everything goes back to
policing because they take so much of
the money they're so you know so
ingrained in every part of our lives and
so i thought you know what i know that
l.a city council is one of the most
powerful city councils in in the country
they oversee four million people
they have tons of resources and why not
try to run for those one of those seats
so i decided to run for city council i
filed in september of 2020 uh because i
knew that you know
if my goal is to get rid of the lapd to
build the just world and mellie's name
and the name of all these other people
who've been killed by police
that i would have to use every approach
that i possibly could and i've always
seen my my race for city council as an
avenue that i can take to get what i
what the justice that i think melly
deserves and and the you know the the
path to abolition can start at city
council my my sort of strategy of
running for city council is is is
talking about my lived experience
because ultimately that's all we kind of
have you know we i didn't go to college
i didn't go to a nice schools or or have
my my path written out for myself i just
kind of you know i was i was forced into
this world that i was i was brought into
this world by by a horrific tragedy and
so to me
you know this is this is now who i am
you know the the i went from being sort
of you know slightly maybe-ish political
albert to now this is my life's work and
i will i will never not be involved in
some sort of movement um to bring and at
the end to policing whether that's city
council or
10 other things i could be working on um
this is just who i am now and it's you
know it's uh you know there's times
where i wish i would have found myself
to the work um while mellie was still
alive and it didn't take this big
horrific tragedy and and you know but
unfortunately that's that's you know
that's my life and i have to live with
that the protest outside of the trader
joe's in silver lake they were calling
it the march for belly we have some
video to show you earlier where there
were several hundred people outside of
the trader joe's uh here in silver lake
all i can do is try to make up for for
the years that i should have been out
there marching for people you know
marching for trayvon martin or or oscar
grant i should have been there but i
wasn't so now i just have to give myself
to this movement
and
that's that's what i plan to do
you